let's talk about the diet for peripheral
neuropathy
now what is peripheral neuropathy
it is a condition where you're
experiencing tingling
numbness or burning type pain in the
bottom of your feet or your
fingertips and the most common way you
would get peripheral neuropathy
is by having diabetes
and so peripheral neuropathy first
starts
in the longer nerves of the body okay
and it
happens at the very end of that nerve
and what's happening is you're getting a
destruction
of the tiny blood vessels to the nerves
and the destruction is not necessarily
coming from
the high sugar directly or high blood
glucose
directly the high blood glucose is
creating
a lot of inflammation free radical
damage
and destruction to the proteins
on the inside of your artery so it's
going to clog this thing up
it's going to starve the blood supply to
the nerve now why is that blood supply
there
to feed the nerve oxygen and nutrients
and so peripheral neuropathy is
basically killing off
the nerves so we're getting
microvascular
damage also it's happening in the eye
too if you're a diabetic
but what i want to tell you especially
if you're new to my channel
and you have peripheral neuropathy it is
actually very very easy
to undo this condition and get relief if
you
simply see this high sugar right here
start consuming low carbs that's called
a healthy ketogenic
diet start doing low carbs immediately
i am blown away how many people
with peripheral neuropathy don't know
this information
they're doing a high carb diet and
they're on the medication and they're
suffering
so bad it's completely unnecessary
this condition can be reversed so you
start doing
low carbohydrate especially if you're
consuming high carbohydrates
with protein like most people do or high
carb
with fat like an ice cream something
like that
you're creating more damage than just
carbs alone when you combine a carb with
a protein
you create something called glycation
which basically destroys certain
proteins in the body that
now become permanent it's very difficult
to undo that
and it clogs up all sorts of things as
in circulation
you also want to make sure that you have
very low amounts of omega-6 oils in the
diet
like for example the corn oil the soy
oil that's in the
salad dressing it's in so many foods
especially if you go out to eat very
often because that's what they cook
everything with
it's also in the soups it's in the
breads and all that stuff
and then you also want to combine
intermittent fasting
both of those together will put you in
really good shape and i put a link down
below
of exactly how to do it but there's
three additional things that can
help you get relief immediately
you can get these from the health of
store benfotiamine
this is a fat soluble b1 i would take
four capsules a day spread them out
what this does is it helps to lower
the inflammation and the damage that's
created from the high sugar
because the high sugar in your blood has
created
a huge need for more
b1 and so what the body will do is
starts to deplete your
b1 reserves until the point where you
have no more
and then you can't actually make the
myelin sheath around the nerve which is
the
insulating fat layer so you can't make
that without b1
so you start putting it back in there
and things start to
heal up alpha lipoic acid is another
very important
one and even this on its own has been
known to improve
peripheral neuropathies so you can take
this as a supplement you can get it
anywhere
and also tocatrinos this is a type of
vitamin
e that works 50 times stronger than
tocopherols
it's a powerful antioxidant all three of
these together
plus the diet with intermittent fasting
would be a very
powerful weapon against peripheral
neuropathy
before you go if you have a question
about a product or
you're new to keto and you want to know
how to begin keto
or you're on keto and you need a debug
because it's not going as smooth
i have a keto consultant standing by to
help you
this is just for the people in the u.s
hopefully in the future we'll be able to
answer everyone's call
but i put the number down below so you
can call and get some help